da würde er sich wieder zahlreich
gewünscht es tut mir so häufig in die
kommentare geschrieben dass ich mal
wieder auf videos von euch reagieren
soll
schreiende begeisterung ihr durftet mir
bei twitter videos einsenden wo ihr
irgendeinen schwachsinn macht und die
schauen wir uns heute gemeinsam an
kauf dir welche
danke danke für ein video in dem ihr
eine schnecke gezeigt wird habe ich noch
nie gesehen so ein ding
b
was ist das
warum hätte smiley damit menschen nicht
gesehen ziemlich abstoßen
[Applaus]
als nächstes wird mir jetzt ja also ein
video eingeschickt wo irgendwelche
kinder auf einem drehstuhl mülltonne
umhauen also ich weiß nicht ob es nur
bei mir so war aber bei uns hat man in
der schule gelernt mal schauen was die
noch so machen
[Musik]
da habe ich eine ganz gute idee und
hilfe für euch und zwar könnt ihr euch
mal hier bewerben
das ist eine superserie die können ich
glaube ich echt weiterhelfen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also wir sehen hier noch die taube
rumstehen und jetzt kommt der fuß an
vorne und hier stoppt dann machen wir
hier kurz stoppen
hier sieht man dass die taube das ist
eine neue szene ist und die taube wort
wecke photoshop also bevor irgendwann
den kommentaren diesen macher des videos
attackieren sollte da angehen sollte von
wegen hey das ist tierquälerei was sie
eine traube weggetreten auf der treppe
ist fake aber trotzdem scheiße dass er
da mit weggetreten hat da muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen
also ich meine ich finde es gut wenn man
gegen die fds ohne jetzt mal hier der
politische meinung einfließen zu lassen
aber ich glaube jeder weiß dass die afg
komplett beschlossen ist in der tat
wenig gut dass ihr direkt sagt hey ihr
seid gegen die afg aber da ein plakat zu
klauen und vandalismus zu betreiben
nicht so dass aller klicks kommen fünf
neue sachen in den shop
ich kann ja auch mal was zeigen was
reinkommt also dieser rudi wird auf
jeden fall am ersten 12 99 shop kommen
die shop url solltet ihr glaube ich
erkennen das ist ein hellblauer bisschen
over size hoodie mit dem umgedrehten
weißes meile hier ich weiß ja mein ding
natürlich erkennen kann doch da sieht
man den und die kordeln sind so so
seemann mäßig fand ich ganz cool das
design können ja nicht mal anziehen
wollen wir nun allerdings direkt mal zum
nächsten video und zwar wurde mir dort
ein meerschweinchen eingesendet bzw wie
meerschweinchen gesendet wurde ein video
von einem meerschweinchen gesendet da
denkt man auf den ersten blick erstmal
okay das ist irgendwie so
meerschweinchen was dagegen dem ding rom
knapp hat man weiß noch nicht genau was
das ist erfährt man jetzt aber ja
hat jemand einfach sein meerschweinchen
mein sticker umklammern gegeben woher
hast du den sticker eigentlich um
dadurch noch mal kurz auf den shop zu
sprechen zu kommen
am ersten zwölf ist dieses jahr zum
ersten mal keine sticker geben beim
launch sondern autogrammkarten ja
signierte autogrammkarten meine damen
und herren erstes mal hilfe
er wird
tatsächlich aus diesen elian
christo das kunst an videos aber das
hier
meine pizza
der ist auch ganz süß bei dem wieder
habe ich nur auf den ersten blick
gedacht hey voll süßen hund und katz und
spielen miteinander doch im zweiten dann
sehen wir schon irgendwie gedacht
das sieht so aus als würden die sich
gegenseitig töten wollen also ich wäre
da vorsichtig bei hund und katze
oh gott ich kenne diese video so
irgendwie etwas vormacht damit auf eine
person raten gezoomt und naja wir
schauen wir weiter so eine art von video
ist okay da der junge jetzt alles
perfekt ausgerechnet hat kann er jetzt
den ratschlag super nachmachen
[Musik]
also das ist
ich kann nicht nur klatschen sehr sehr
sehr sehr süßes video was mir
eingeschickt wurde alpakas sind wirklich
meine absoluten lieblingstiere
die sache ist nur die sind ein bisschen
dumm und auch bei dem video hier sieht
man irgendwie zu beginn das ist
irgendwie versucht die wand anzuknabbern
ja die haben schon echt ein rad ab
vielleicht passen die tiere deswegen
auch so gut zu mir
[Musik]
wenn man vom teufel spricht kommt hier
noch ein video mit luca - shop.de drin
erster zwölfter leute ihr wisst bescheid
und freue mich
ich erhoffe mir nun allerdings auch zum
letzten video was mir wieder auf twitter
unter dem hashtag luca reagiert 1
gesendet wurde und zwar ist es dieses
mädel die ja sie will glaube ich sushi
essen bis hier versetzt euch mal meine
lage ich sitze hier einmal wöchentlich
und poster auf twitter com schickt mir
videos ein und dann kommen da videos wie
jemand mit einem stuhl gegen eine
mülltonne fährt dann ist da noch jemand
der an seinen meerschweinchen einziger
von mir verfüttert und dann kommen da
auch noch solche leute die nicht essen
können das hier das ist das ist mein
schreibtisch aber das alles hier ist
echt ein absolutes lieblings format an
der stelle möglich mein heutiges videos
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wenn euch diese folge luca
reagiert gefallen hat lasse gerne mal
ein leichter schreibt mir gerne und in
die kommentare ob ich dieses format
wieder öfter bringen soll
[Musik]